Benjamin Netanyahu might be down but
he's not out not yet before a meeting
with senior members of his the could
party
he said he'd agreed to form a block of
right-wing and ultra Orthodox religious
parties along with Likud as a basis for
a new government under his leadership
there are one or two options either a
government headed by me or a dangerous
government that's leaning on the Arab
parties at this moment more than at any
other and in the face of the security
and political challenges that are on
ahead it's forbidden that the government
will be formed that is leaning on the
anti Zionist Arab parties the bloc in
question would give him 55 seats in the
Israeli Parliament or Knesset still six
short of the 61 needed to form a
majority coalition
it's a rebuke to Netanyahu's former ally
Avigdor Lieberman who's insisted that
his party Israel by 10 o be could and
the opposition blue and white combined
to form a secular unity government yes
all conclusion is clear although we have
said during the election campaign is
coming true there's only one option a
national unity government a liberal
broad government we will not join any
other option but if Netanyahu is
refusing as he clearly is now to join
that option where does he get the six
seats he needs for a government Amir
Peretz his left-wing labor Geshe
Alliance temptingly has just that number
but he refused again on Wednesday to sit
with Netanyahu Benny Gant's has said his
blue and white alliance with 32 seats
will stay together and his secularist
partner Yair Lapid would be unlikely to
serve with Netanyahu's ultra-orthodox
allies nor they with him we will wait
another day or two and wish the people
of Israel a good necessary unity
government that the system will calm
down a little bit and we will move along
ganses own prospects could be improved
of the mainly Palestinian Israeli joint
list now the third biggest party in the
Knesset recommends him for prime
minister it could even be a step on the
road to what its leader I'm an Oda says
he wants to head the Official Opposition
Netanyahu's post election play is
certainly an attempt to carry on making
the political weather but in a sign that
this is a crisis for a man who in just
two weeks
faces his first pre-indictment
corruption hearing he's also cancelled
his appearance at next week's United
Nations General Assembly in New York
staying home no doubt to focus on :
building but also perhaps to ensure that
isla could party stays in line behind
him Harry faucet al Jazeera
West Jerusalem